Speaker 1: So there's a new report out that,
while shocking, shouldn't be hugely surprising
to anybody who's been paying attention for
the last six years.
In a new book by Wall Street Journal reporter
Michael Bender, Bender writes that Donald
Trump told his then chief of staff, John Kelly,
in 2018 that Hitler, yes, Adolf Hitler did
a lot of good things.
Now, remember that The Wall Street Journal
is owned by News Corp.
That's the same company that owns Fox News.
This is not some left wing publication or
left wing reporter.
The story goes that this took place during
a visit to Europe for the 100th anniversary
of the end of World War One.
Now, you might I actually remember this was
one of the many disastrous trips that Trump
took.
And I believe this was the one where he ended
up not going somewhere and they claimed it
was because of fog.
But he just wanted to hang around and watch
Fox News.
There was like some Leeth ring wreath laying
ceremony, something like that.
I believe that's the same trip here.
And during that trip, Donald Trump insisted
to John Kelly, who at the time was his chief
of staff, that, well, Hitler did a lot of
good things.
The comments reportedly stunned John Kelly.
This is all in a book that's hilariously titled,
frankly, we did win this election.
You know, that's that's Trump, the guy, of
course, who is saying that.
Speaker 2: Congratulations, sir.
You just won the election.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Now, the comment itself is outrageous
and stunning.
There are rumors that Trump used to keep a
copy of Hitler's speeches on his bedside table.
Trump doesn't read.
That's the one thing that makes me doubt that.
But it's certainly possible.
But the context here is actually even more
interesting.
Trump apparently blurted this out during the
trip when John Kelly started explaining basic
history to Trump.
I guess, as was frequently done before an
event, people around Trump would try to give
him a little information about how the world
works so that he would maybe be able to avoid
humiliating himself.
And in so doing, John Kelly reminded Trump,
what were the different countries on each
side of World War One?
And then Kelly explained how World War One
connected to World War Two and of course,
the Holocaust and the atrocities of Adolf
Hitler.
And in that context, Trump's contribution,
Trump's interjection was, well, Hitler did
a lot of good things to an American president.
Fox reportedly saying this.
Now, of course, Trump's new spokeswoman, Liz
Harington, says it's all made up.
She says, quote, This is totally false.
President Trump never said this.
It is made up fake news probably by a general
who was incompetent and was fired.
However, Bender seems to have done his job
and his homework and has multiple sources
on this.
And in fact, multiple people told Bender everybody
in the room was saying to Trump, no, no, no,
no, no, Hitler didn't do great things.
And they were clearly horrified that Trump
might say that publicly at some point.
And Trump reportedly insisted, according to
multiple sources, no, Hitler did do great
things like, for example, leading the German
economic recovery in the nineteen thirties.
Now, even that shows Trump's complete ignorance
and his deference to authoritarian and in
some cases genocidal leaders.
Trump seems to have no idea that the so-called
German economic revival was hugely based on
wealth that they stole from the people that
they eventually murdered.
What I would have given to have been a fly
on the wall during this conversation and Bender
ads in the book that Kelly told Trump, even
if your claim about the German economy under
the Nazis was true, like even if it were true
that Hitler did great things economically,
quote, you cannot ever say anything supportive
of Adolf Hitler.
You just can't.
And Kelly clearly realized that if he didn't
explain that to Trump, next thing you know,
Trump might be praising Hitler in public.
And the book more generally outlines how clueless
Trump was about every aspect of history.
Quote, Senior officials described his understanding
of slavery, Jim Crow or the black experience
in general post civil war as vague to nonexistent.
But Trump's indifference to black history
was similar to his disregard for the history
of any race, religion or creed.
It's actually crazy, but this sounds like
the type of things some Trump supporters would
actually say in defending Trump.
Like when you confront a Trump supporter and
you say, listen, Trump is really authoritarian.
His tendencies are like Duterte and they're
like Kim Jong un and they're like Putin.
And, you know, some aspects are even Hitlerian
in some way.
OK, man.
But Hitler did some good things.
I mean, the economy did well in the trains,
ran on time or whatever.
It sounds exactly like the prototypical Trump
supporter, and I don't typically read these
types of books, I didn't read Fire and Fury,
I didn't read, you know, all of these different
ones.
Frankly, we did win this election.
Sounds like one I may actually want to look
at, but certainly nothing.
It's shocking, but it's not a surprise if
you've been following Donald Trump for as
long as anybody who's been following American
politics has been doing it.
And curious to see if Trump will say anything
about it himself.
Hey, you know,